the city of lyons it's the commune of
rio la papa it's home to around 30
000 people who are experiencing an
extreme
flare-up of urban violence terrorized by
groups of young people who are said to
be out of control
burned vehicles police officers
regularly targeted
cars stoned it's too much for some
to bear in 47 years of living here i
have never witnessed this before
it used to be a city healed as an
example to follow
but over the years the situation has
become intolerable
burning cars violence and verbal abuse
it's a shame because it's a city that's
been completely reborn
but all this violence is very
discouraging
the situation is quite worrying our car
could be set alight at any
time but the worst part is that all the
young people that could be doing
something constructive
are actually wasting their time and
causing trouble
the problem has been brewing for a long
time
but now the local mayor who's been under
pressure to find a solution
finally has one it's simple he wants
citizens to stand up
and denounce the delinquents on a new
national police reporting platform
even if it's their own child
if a mother or father realizes that
their child has assaulted a police
officer
or exhibited violent behavior is the
responsibility of that parent to act and
prevent their child from falling into
serious delinquency
the aim is very simple to break the
circle of violence
but also to tell parents to wake up
has experienced a number of issues with
urban violence of late
and its mayor has been in the thick of
it he's had
death threats made against him the
problems here are similar to those in
the neighboring city you've brought
it's against a backdrop of reinforced
fighting
against drug trafficking that's being
carried out by
national and municipal forces though
some say the issues stem from social
problems
that are being blamed on the authorities
themselves in a recent
spate of violence around 10 vehicles
were burned in one
week while back in march a bus driver
was forced to abandon his vehicle
before it was set on fire many of those
who are said to be
wrecking havoc are as young as 11.
that's left the mayor questioning why
parents
aren't more engaged
i realize that the offenders behind this
violence are just children
aged 12 13 or 14. i'd like to tell the
parents to be careful because their
children
are heading in the wrong direction what
is happening now is not a game
being a parent is not just about lying
on the sofa not caring where your
children are hanging out
especially during the curfew well the
fear of violence
in the community is real this idea of
making people
snitch particularly on their family
members
isn't popular with all the police have
raised concerns saying
this could actually be counterproductive
the risk is to have a large mass of
information including
information that might be totally wrong
it then becomes important investigative
work to carry out
but the plan does apparently have the
backing of france's interior minister
gerhard damon
what residents will now have to decide
is what is
more important to them is it reporting
their own for the sake and safety of
their community
or standing silent as the violence
escalates
shola tubinski rt paris